This 5-minute trading strategy is by far
the easiest way to become profitable
fast, and it works so well that it
almost feels like cheating. If someone
had told me this 14 years ago when I
started trading, I would have been able
to get wins like this, this, and this
much sooner. Today, you'll learn how
this simple approach will help you avoid
the fatal mistakes that plague most
traders. That way you can cut out the
wasted time and effort and become
consistently profitable much sooner.
Let's hop right into the first step you
need to take. So, before we get into the
actual strategy, I'm going to talk to
you guys about three problems that so
many traders fall into. And I like to
categorize these into three different
buckets. So, most traders never become
profitable not because the market's
impossible, it's because they're stuck
in one of these three loops. And I have
three different buckets for the
struggling trader. So, the first bucket
is the over-thinker. So, anybody that's
an over-thinker just suffers from
analysis paralysis, meaning you have way
too many indicators, you're studying way
too many different time frames, you're
looking at conflicting signals, meaning
you don't know whether to be bullish or
bearish, you know, one minute you're
bullish, next minute you're bearish just
based on how the candles are printing.
Maybe you never pull the trigger, or
maybe you're pulling the trigger way too
many times, and you don't have a system.
And maybe you're over-thinking what it
is that you're actually trying to do.
So, this might be somebody that has tons
of indicators on the charts, but
actually doesn't know how to apply one
of them. They just keep adding
indicators to the chart thinking that
it's going to improve their edge. Maybe
you're watching five plus time frames at
once and not really dialing in on what
signal is being provided at one specific
time. So, if you're the type of trader
that sits down in front of the charts,
and let's say if you don't see a setup
on the hourly time frame, which is your
typical time frame, you might be
dropping down to lower lower time frames
to try and find a setup. And this is
where analysis paralysis comes into play
is because you don't see a setup on that
higher time frame, which you typically
trade, and now all of a sudden you're
trying to analyze every little thing
about the market to try and find a setup
and try and force a setup. So, the fix
here as an over-thinker isn't to learn
more, it's about learning to apply what
you already know. Now, the best traders
that I know, they use less information
than you'd think. They're watching one
thing on the chart, looking for one
pattern, waiting for one specific event
to happen, and when it does, they just
execute. There's no debating, there's no
hesitating, there's no thinking about
what might happen. They're not really
concerned about the outcome of a
specific trade. They just have a plan,
they execute that plan to the best of
their ability, and accept the outcome,
whatever it is, win or loss. Now, as an
over-thinker, you're probably one that
is trying to find every little reason
why a trade failed or why it worked,
which is kind of the opposite of how a
professional trader thinks. They don't
think about all the different reasons
why they lose a trade. You have to
understand that trading is a game of
probability. You are going to lose on
trades, and you're going to lose on a
lot of them if you want to do this for a
long period of time. So, instead of
trying to over-analyze why something did
or didn't go in your favor, instead just
accept the outcome and try and be better
next time. And maybe there is no room
for improvement. Maybe you followed
everything to a T, and in that case, you
probably just want to journal the
outcome and move on. Because a lot of
times when you try and sit there and
analyze what went wrong on the trade,
maybe nothing went wrong, which causes
you to try and over-refine your system.
Now, there is a specific sequence of
price action, call it a pattern, and
once you recognize it, it eliminates
every ounce of hesitation. And this
happens nearly every single day in the
same windows of time. So, once I show
you guys what it looks like, you're
going to be furious at how long you
spent over-complicating your trading.
All right, bucket number two, the
gambler. That's somebody that trades on
impulse with no defined rules. They
don't have an edge, and you don't have
any respect for risk management. So, you
have no consistent entry criteria or
exit criteria. Your position sizes are
changing based on your emotions, so
maybe you're chasing your losses, maybe
you're getting frustrated, and you're
revenge trading after you take losses.
Now, you don't need more discipline, you
need a system that makes this discipline
irrelevant. So, when your rules are
specific, there's nothing left to decide
emotionally. Your entry is defined, your
stop loss is defined, your target is
defined, and your frequency is defined,
meaning how many attempts am I going to
give this one specific trade example
before I abandon it and step away. And
think about this like an actual gambler
at a casino. Sometimes the tables are
hot, and sometimes they're cold. The
professional players know when to step
away from a cold table, whereas the
gambler doesn't. They chase their losses
and they sit there and wait for the next
hand to come out, hoping that the
table's going to turn hot all of a
sudden. So, you have to understand again
that this is a game of probability.
You're going to have days that are low
probability. And if you give it one or
two attempts and it doesn't work out,
you have to know how to get off the desk
and do something else productive with
your time. Maybe that's back testing,
maybe it's journaling, maybe it's trying
to refine your systems a little bit
more. But overall, you need to have some
type of mechanism that gets you off of
the desk so that you don't become a
gambler. Now, what I'm going to show you
with the strategy is how to know your
exact risk reward before you even touch
the buy or sell button. And why the
structure behind the setup makes revenge
trading almost impossible because the
next valid entry is not going to appear
until the market gives you this very
specific signal. And when the signal
shows up, you might give one or two
cracks at it. If it doesn't work, it's
time to get off the desk. Number three
is the strategy hopper. So, this is
somebody that jumps from system to
system chasing the holy grail without
ever mastering one approach. you have a
new strategy every week. You blame the
method and never the execution. You have
no data or no journal and no reps. So,
the biggest problem with strategy
hoppers is that they don't trade the
system long enough to understand if it
has an edge or not long term. So, let's
say if you find a system that works 50%
of the time and you're somewhat
profitable with it. So, instead of
trying to just refine that system that's
already somewhat profitable, instead
they're trying to find a strategy that
has a better win rate, has a better risk
reward, right? They don't go through
those slumps of trading and they just
aren't accepting the fact that there is
no holy grail. A strategy that works 40
to 50% of the time is enough to make you
rich. So, I want you guys to stop
searching for new strategies. Find
something that works even just 40 to 50%
of the time and learn how to execute it
better. So, what you actually need is an
approach that's rooted in how the market
is actually engineered to move. And that
strategy needs to be built on structure
instead of signals. So, that way when
you go through a rough market condition,
you just try and trade through that and
stick to the same strategy. So, what I'm
going to show you guys is based on logic
and once you see where the real moves
originate from, you'll understand why
this works in any market, in any
timeframe, and in any session. So,
again, the three problems that most
traders fall into are one of these three
and a lot of traders kind of are on
repeat. They kind of just stay in this
loop of testing and over-analyzing,
gambling, strategy hopping, and they
just keep cycling between these three
and never move to the next phase of
profitable trading, which is having a
solidified strategy that you can follow
in any market condition and you're going
to accept any outcome that comes from
the market. Because again, you only need
a 40 to 50% win rate to be profitable in
the markets. So, let's talk about the
actual strategy and this is the daily
sweep strategy. There's five steps, no
indicators, there's no guessing. You
just let the market show you where the
liquidity is and what does it actually
do with it. So, what we're going to do
is wait for a sweep and then strike. So,
now markets are designed to hunt
liquidity. The daily sweep strategy uses
this to your advantage letting the
market show its hand first. Now, I
cannot emphasize this enough. So many
traders are trying to anticipate what
the next move in the market is rather
than waiting for the market to show its
hand. So, have you ever been in a trade
where you think it's going to go in one
specific direction, you're impatient,
you enter the market, and then all of a
sudden the easier hand to read shows up
after you've been stopped out. That's
exactly what we're waiting for. We want
to see something in the market that
gives us an indication that it's showing
its hand to us and then we can position
ourselves properly. So, the core
principle here is that we're not trying
to predict where price is going to go.
We're waiting for the market to actually
show us by sweeping liquidity, closing
back above or below a level, and then we
want to participate. So, step one here
is we're going to mark out our previous
day's swing points. So, we're going to
identify all of the previous day's swing
highs and lows. That might include Asian
session, the previous 24-hour trading
session, and all of the price action
leading up to the New York open. Now,
these are all the liquidity pools where
stop losses are resting and where
institutions will look to transact,
Maybe institutions or big traders. Then
what we're going to wait for is the
liquidity sweep. So, price is going to
push beyond that swing point, triggering
those stop losses or trapping the
breakout traders. This is the market
hunting liquidity. And we don't want to
react just yet. We would just want to
observe. Step number three is we're
going to wait for a closure back above
or below the swing point. So, if we're
bullish and we sweep a swing low, we
want a closure back above the swing low.
So, again, after the sweep, we wait for
price to close back above the swing low
or below the swing high if we're
bearish. And this closure confirms the
sweep was a trap. And this is the market
showing you its hand. And this is going
to be our signal to then get involved.
Step number four, we're going to try and
find a fair value gap on the 5-minute
time frame. So, we're going to set our
entry at the fair value gap left behind
by the displacement move. And we're
going to use a tight stop above or below
the sweep. You know, maybe you want to
use candle two of a fair value gap. What
we're going to do is target opposing
liquidity or a fixed risk-to-reward. All
right. So, now that you understand how
to find these trades, let's go through a
couple of actual examples. So, example
number one is going to be a bullish
sweep, meaning a fair value gap long.
We're looking for a sweep of an intraday
low into a long entry. So, the trap
springs, we get displacement, which
confirms that we're trying to get long,
and then price delivers to the buy-side
liquidity that we're targeting. So,
let's go through all of the steps of
this specific setup. We have a sweep of
an intraday low into a fair value gap.
Now, in both of these examples, I'm
using the hourly time frame as our
higher time frame. So, here we have
1-hour structure and an SFP. So, leading
up to the New York session, we have this
previous low here. And then you can see
during New York session, we get a nice
run of that low with a closure back
above. And because we're bullish, we're
trading at the low end of this trading
range. So, you can see here, these lows
down in here, as well as these highs.
We're anticipating us trading back to
the highs. Right, this is a bullish
setup. Step number one, price sweeps
below a previous intraday low during the
New York session, grabbing the sell-side
liquidity. Again, we have this previous
low here. We've run out that liquidity
and we've closed back above it, showing
us that anybody that tried to get short
down here is now trapped. Or anybody
that got long a little too early is now
stopped out of the market. Step number
two, aggressive displacement candle back
above the intraday low, creating the
swing failure pattern. Again, we have
that nice aggressive displacement back
above, right? You can see where the
hourly open, we ran out the liquidity,
and then we have a nice strong
aggressive move back up to close above
that low, which creates the swing
failure pattern. Step three, we're
looking for a fair value gap to form on
the 5-minute chart. So, our entry goes
at the midpoint of the fair value gap.
Here's our 5-minute fair value gap. So,
again, we have this nice hourly raid of
the swing low, a nice closure and
displacement above, and then we get a
retest back into the fair value gap.
What we're going to do is enter long
somewhere in this fair value gap,
putting our stop loss below candle two
of the fair value gap. So, step four,
stop placed at candle two of the fair
value gap, and all we're doing is
targeting a fixed 1:3 RR or the buy-side
liquidity. So, we have this entry here,
and all we're trying to do is target
this buy-side liquidity that's here.
Now, again, the key here is that the
sweep below the intraday low was the
trap, and you're trying to analyze this
in real time. Now, once we get that SFP
on the closure of this hourly candle,
it's showing you that smart money is
trying to accumulate longs below that
low. So, this trade example ended in a
3R, and this is a bullish trade example.
So, let's go over a bearish trade
example. So, let's say coming into the
day, I have a bearish bias. What we're
looking for, again, is a sweep of the
intraday high into a short entry,
showing us that the liquidity was
grabbed, meaning buy-side liquidity was
grabbed. We have displacement, showing
us that all the traders that were trying
to get long are now trapped in the
trade, or anybody that was short a
little too early then got stopped out of
the trade. So, if we go over to our
hourly structure, and if we zoom in here
a little bit, we have this Asian range
high, which is our swing high. And based
on yesterday's price action on
Wednesday, we have a nice raid above
that high, but we're waiting for the
closure back below the swing high. Okay,
we're not trying to get short on any one
of these candles up here. We're waiting
for the closure back below the swing
high. So, steps one and two, price
sweeps above the previous intraday high
before the New York open, grabbing that
buy-side liquidity. Step two, aggressive
displacement candle back below the
intraday high, creating the swing
failure pattern. Step number three and
four, waiting for a fair value gap to
form on a 5-minute chart. Maybe your
entry is set at a fair value gap low,
and your stop goes above candle two of
the fair value gap. Your target is a
fixed one to two or one to three, or you
can target the Asian range lows or the
weekly open. So, in this scenario, we
have our Asian range high on an hourly
time frame, we get a nice closure here
at 9:00 a.m. And what we're looking for
is this 5-minute fair value gap. So, we
have a nice 5-minute fair value gap. We
enter as the market's trading into that
fair value gap. The stop goes above
candle two of that fair value gap, and
then we target the Asian range low. So,
this trade example gave us a 5R. So,
quick summary of the daily sweep
strategy. This strategy occurs almost
every single day, but the key here is
that you're only taking one or two
trades a day. Okay, if we miss out on a
setup or if we get stopped out, there's
going to be another trade the next day.
You have to learn how to step away from
the markets when they're not operating
how you think they will. So, key point
here is you wait for the sweep and then
you strike. You want to see the market
showing you its hand. So, what we're
going to do again is mark out all of our
previous day swing points. We're going
to wait for the liquidity sweep, wait
for a closure back above or below,
showing us that the market actually
wants to turn around. And then we're
going to try and find a fair value gap
on the lower time frame. We have a
structured way of finding our entries,
placing our stop losses, and our
targets. And we're just going to rinse
and repeat this forever. You now have a
simple and proven approach to liquidity.
Well, chances are this isn't the only
reason you still aren't profitable. I
know this because I struggled for 10
years before I became profitable, which
is why I created the Trading Apprentice.
This is not your average trading
discord. It's direct access to me, a
verified seven-figure trader and world
record holder, to teach you everything
I've learned in the last 14 years. I'll
leave a link to apply down in the
description. But, I want to be clear, I
don't work with just anyone. If the link
still works, there are slots left.
Otherwise, you can join the waitlist.
And as always, don't forget to like and
subscribe, and I'll see you guys in the
next video.